you make that choice either you can go
this way where it's all bad and cloudy
and feel like a victim or you could feel
like you've conquered everything that
they told you that you couldn't do and
be out here winning so it's like let me
go over here win I started realizing
that something was off with my body when
I was around 14 years old after a while
my mom was in her room and she called me
to the back and she was like you have
ALS and I was like okay and she was like
do you know what that is and I was like
no the role my family and friends played
into my life is so significant my mom
flew down they didn't start babying me
they didn't tell me anything negative
anything that I said I wanted to do they
supported it it was senior year in high
school and we went to grad night
Disneyland and because Disneyland was so
big the school nurse recommended that I
use a motorized wheelchair and it was so
convenient for me I was like well
college is almost as big as Disneyland I
might as well start using a chair and
that's the thing is like I know people
would probably see me in my wheelchair
and think oh it's a wheelchair it's the
worst thing that could ever happen to
somebody but in my case and I do have to
you know put the disclaimer that every
person with the disability is different
if I would have kept walking I probably
would have been more permanent in the
chair one of the major reasons why I
even started my youtube was because I
wanted to show that disability didn't
look sad
it didn't look sloppy it didn't look
medical it could be fly it could be sexy
it could be fun
it could be whatever you wanted it to be
because it's so annoying as a person
with a disability when people think that
you should look a certain way there's
been so many times where people will
come up to me if I'm not in my chair and
be like well you don't look disabled
what the [ __ ] is that supposed to mean
oh so you think I'm supposed to be here
like
oh I'm time my life is the worst and
it's just like no sorry I sit hi
so the average life expectancy for a
person who was diagnosed with ALS is
about five to seven years and given the
fact that I'll be 30 I'm doubled the
life expectancy and then some I used to
have the fear that because I was a woman
in a wheelchair that I wouldn't be able
to do as much as I wanted but I always
have to get back sinners and just
remember in this moment you can either
part on all the things that haven't
happened yet all the fears which is just
a thought it's not even real or you can
look at what is real you still have the
ability to walk you still have the
ability to fit you can have the ability
to speak and open your eyes and with
that alone it's like you know what I'm
going this way and remind myself that I
am always going to push through I'm
always gonna stay positive and I'm going
to do the best that I can to be the best
version of me cuz I sit hi boo
[Music]